there steve kaufman here today i'm going
to talk to you about how to become
fluent in mandarin in six months
let me begin by saying that you can't do
that
however
uh it's a goal
i think one can become quite fluent in
six quite comfortable in six months and
first of all let me explain why i'm
going to talk about that because i
received an email from one of my viewers
here
and he said i am a current student of
banner chinese blah blah blah blah live
in beijing
i have a goal to become professionally
and socially competent in chinese as
quickly and as efficiently as possible
my time frame six months to one year
uh i agree that the classroom is not the
best place to learn a new language
although i plan to use it as a door into
the world of chinese good idea
uh people such as tim ferriss talk about
the pareto's 80 20 principle which i
don't think applies to language learning
but i'll explain why
and i have spoken he says you have
spoken about material over method
well maybe talk about that
but he says
in the interest of discovering what can
work best for a language i'd like to
take advantage of your extensive
expertise if you flatter me i'll always
uh accommodate you
um
in your pursuit of chinese fluency what
would you say were the most effective
exercises or methods you used for
example speaking with a native
one-on-one reading chinese novels comics
two what sort of helpful exposure to the
chinese language did you have that
others may not have thought of or
encouraged three what is the biggest
waste of time four if i had to teach
myself what books or materials would you
recommend
and next if you had to train me
intensively
how would you drill me so this is the
thing
okay
fluent in six months okay
where i come unstuck with this idea of
fluent three months six months nine
months twelve months is the assumption
is that you're gonna do something in six
months that that then it's you've
finished it you've completed it you've
now done it
language learning is not like that
uh
what you want to achieve in six months
or nine months
is
this
language potential that is going to
enable you
to improve a lot
as you continue to use the language
you because uh in all the languages that
i speak i am better now than i ever have
been
bear in mind if i leave a language like
right now i'm trying to study italian
and i last night i was at a party with
some brazilians and for the first 10-15
minutes i was falling all over myself
speaking italian rather than portuguese
but towards the end of the evening i got
better and that's only in one evening
and i think that
if i were
in brazil for a couple of days
my
portuguese would get better than it ever
has been
my mandarin chinese is better today than
it was when i finished my
10 months of intensive training even
though at that time i could write
longhand i can't do that now
what i'm trying to say is that any
language is a lifelong journey
all you can do in a period of three six
nine months is get yourself up to that
level so that you can now engage people
in more or less intelligent
conversations you can start to read
things that are more or less
interesting
uh and then you will just continue to
improve and the more you use the
language the better you will get and
it's like a snowball the more you have
the more you can engage in meaningful
conversations the more interesting
material you can use and so forth and so
on so with that in mind i think the goal
is to get comfortable so that you can
comfortably interact with people in
meaningful situations
comfortably
access authentic material even though
you're going to stumble but it's
comfortable because you don't worry
about stumbling and you know that it's a
long road so with that in mind here's
what i would recommend for mandarin
chinese if the sky's the limit
or for that matter for me if i were
taking a new language say turkish
go to the place where the language is
spoken go there right away if nothing
else matters money doesn't matter just
go there i have often said you're better
off to wait until you have some exposure
to the language before going if you want
to basically optimize the opportunity
you know maximize the return on
investment but if you're not worried
about a return on investment go there
because you'll be surrounded by the
language it's a constant incentive to
learn the language you have every time
you learn something you might notice it
on a shop
window or you hear it on the radio and
all of this stimulates you to keep going
so that's number one well our friend
here has written me the email he's
already in beijing so that's good
the second thing is if i remember and
this is specific to mandarin
my first month with mandarin we had a
thing called chinese dialogues
it was spoken
i thought so quickly
that i thought they were doing it
deliberately
to annoy us it was so annoyingly fast
and we only had pinyin or in those days
wade giles
which is a different system of using uh
you know the latin alphabet roman
alphabet to describe chinese
so we read it phonetically and we
listened to it and i listened to it over
and over and over again and i i was so
annoyed by how fast they seem to speak
but i think that was very good for me
and you know i've often thought about
should you begin by learning the
characters or not and so forth i think
in the case of chinese where we're
dealing with tones and all these other
things
i look back on it now probably not a bad
idea because then when you start
learning the characters
you're learning the characters for words
you have already heard and maybe know
and know the meaning of
and the vocabulary in these initial
dialogues is pretty basic and so as you
start learning the characters anytime
you can learn something
uh try to study something that you
already have a point of reference for
you're going to learn it better you're
going to be more curious
i always quote the famous sufi saying
you can only learn what you already know
it's a slight overstatement but that's
why i always say with grammar once you
have enough you know
input and and experience with the
language the grammar rules start to make
sense you actually want to learn them
because you've come across these
structures in your listening and reading
so with mandarin first thing is first
month just listen to these simple
dialogues many times and if they're too
fast for you that's probably good
and i would suggest maybe laying off the
characters for the first month that's
number one number two once you start the
characters you have to have a program i
started with 10 a day and i got it up to
30 a day granted you're going to forget
most of them but you have to relearn
them and relearn them and i've described
in on many occasions how i use this
you know
checkered paper and wrote them out
longhand and put the meaning over three
columns and then
soon would run into that again and keep
on doing that and i would do i started
out of 10 i got it up to 30. and so i
think that kind some kind of a spaced
repetition system like that characters
you got to spend an hour a day
and you have to do it every day
every day so if this person
is in beijing he's got all the time the
world wants to learn chinese an hour a
day on characters because that's your
major stumbling block until you have the
characters you can't read and i believe
that reading is very important to
acquiring vocabulary
then the next thing is what were the
most effective exercise the most
effective thing to do is to listen and
read in my opinion
uh i you know if i went to turkey you
know you talk about this one-on-one with
a native yes after three months but not
initially because i don't know enough of
the language and i find it
kind of uh i don't like being put in the
position where a teacher is drilling me
i just don't like doing that i'd rather
discover the language on my own and when
i'm able to defend myself and understand
what the teacher is saying then we can
actually get into a conversation so in
the meantime just that massive exposure
and as hard as you can go at it and if
you're full time of course you can vary
things so you can work on your
characters you can work on your
listening and reading
i mean you want to to keep your
incentive up by all means have a
one-on-one session but don't sit in a
classroom listening to other non-native
speakers mangle a language i would never
never do that
um
helpful exposure that others may not
have had no i mean we the main thing was
that
i went to bookstores all the time in
hong kong
and i looked for there was a geography
book at 300 characters there's a history
book of 600 characters there was i was
constantly scouring bookstores
for readers with glossaries and that
were graded for
character level
and so i think that's important biggest
waste of time is looking up a
conventional dictionary because it's so
time consuming in the case of chinese
and you have to assume that whatever you
look up in a dictionary you're going to
forget you're going to forget it as soon
as you close the dictionary half the
time you'll go right back to the context
and you'll forget what it was you saw in
the dictionary unless you're a lot
better than i am and and
i think a lot of people have the same
experience it's just too difficult again
you don't have enough things to tie it
to
so if i had to teach myself what books
are materials you have to go out and
search for materials and no one's going
to give it to you you have to go and now
you can i mean everything is so much
better now than when i was doing chinese
you can look for material on the
internet of course you can go to
bookstores you don't have to use
traditional
lookup dictionaries you can have online
dictionaries you can use link so you
stay in the context so you don't go off
and look something up close the
dictionary come back what was that
so
you know
use whatever you can find
constantly be looking for new stuff
and just keep on feeding it into that's
what i did
another thing is i would start to write
as soon as i can now here again there
are things that you can do that i
couldn't do for example
you can write
and then very quickly on google
translate see how far off you were
because your thoughts are going to start
in english you write something out in
chinese your struggle whatever then go
to google translate type it in or if you
have a mac you can use the dictation and
you can actually speak it and up pops
the japanese so you can actually be
practicing your writing or if you're at
link you can write something put it on
the exchange somebody will come along
and correct it for you uh if you had to
train me intensively for a month what
would the program look like well it
wouldn't be very different from what i'm
saying now
uh i wouldn't drill you
i wouldn't drill you i would tell you to
go away and fill your brain with chinese
listening to it reading it learn
characters and when you're ready come
back and we're going to start talking
and when we talk i'm going to make notes
of your mistakes and you're going to get
a list of those mistakes to take away
and study i'll try not to interrupt you
when we're speaking
which is essentially again what we do in
our online conversations at link where
we send these reports through that
people study
so uh there you have it uh that's for
chinese and i think after six months oh
two quick things here tim ferriss talks
about the 80 20 principle you know and i
presume this refers to learn the you
know the the uh
20 of the words are used give you 80 of
the content i have never found that to
be such a useful concept the
eighty percent in other words that
twenty percent of words that account for
eighty percent of the context of any
conversation you're going to come across
them naturally anyway however to get
into meaningful conversations to
understand what people are saying you
will find that you need a lot of words
that's been my experience
the most frequent eighty percent will
take care of themselves don't worry
about it you have to worry about how to
stay motivated so that you can learn the
many many words that you need to engage
in meaningful conversation with people
you know
intelligent conversation to read books
to read the newspaper to read magazines
to understand movies you need a lot of
words so the 80 20 doesn't apply um
then he said that i spoke of material
over method i'm not quite sure what that
means but
as i've said many times motivation
initiative time with the language
developing that ability to notice and
there's again where a teacher can help
you because there are certain things
that you just won't notice and the
teacher can point them out
uh and so
the method really to me is a lot of
exposure and then starting to speak and
when you start speaking you just keep
going and don't worry don't worry like
is this his third tone or the second
door just speak
just speak
uh so that's so i think you can achieve
a lot in six months
and if it's a european language even
three months you can get to that
threshold level
you know i sometimes have talked about
this upside down hockey stick where the
first
three months or so is very difficult but
you are aware of making progress because
a previously unintelligible language is
now intelligible but then there is that
long period and that's why i say don't
think in terms of what you're going to
master it in six months you're not
you're going to get yourself up to a
level and then you've got a long road
and uh if you're
in china there uh you're probably young
you're not gonna learn chinese and
forget it you're gonna have chinese with
you
for your whole life and it will continue
getting better or it should if you
develop habits of reading and listening
and so forth and so on
before i leave you i just want to say
that again i've gone a bit long here but
i was up in whistler at a lumber
industry conference and on my way up
there and back i was listening to
italian so i'm going to leave as a
little trailer here
driving down with uh howe sound on my
right and i'm listening to ipro messi
sposey and he's describing the lag with
como and of course the fjord the house
sound is a bit reminiscent of lago di
como and so it's just this whole idea of
how reading and listening can take you
off into different centuries
different countries different languages
and
it's a constant source of enjoyment with
the language and i might enjoy uh
listening to an italian audiobook 20
years from now
as i did when i listened 20 years ago
so your languages are always with you
thank you for listening bye for now